ん
me
入道いいいい
すごいプレッシャーかけた
あっ
しかも表題はなんか約6+からっていうか自分で自分を否定するやじ学的なようだに
なっちゃってるんですけどまぁそれは反論してみたいっ
それで
や様から歴史が好きだった方はどういう風にいらっしゃいますちょっとやれん
高校までの歴史で
好きになっちゃったっ
もう嫌なちゃったって文化です
何か影響が組まれた人大杉様みたいです
いやー日産すればてよく聞くのは特に理系の人がですねもうれっ子なんて本当に嫌だっ
たということをよく聞くんですね
無理もないんです
これ
傭兵があったと思うんですが
は東西でなんかできお受験科目は選んだらこうなっちゃうんですね
この教科書まずゆゆのが
基本だと言われています中身は確かにいいものだろうと私は思いますけれどもんでも
はっきりとあんま面白くない
私自身の4回したいと思います
まあですからこういうのを読んでる受験メイクした人はこういう風に考えています
もいもない
だけれどもまた自身あのこれ読んでですねすぐに出てくる単語です眠上げ覚えたり
先の年後年代を覚えたいって大変苦痛に思います
なんとか知的な虐待をしている k 管理をすることがある
でも実際に私がですねあの歴史の研究やってる場合は面白くてたまらないわけですね
こういう教科書のイメージと実際私たちで力を天日しているものはずいぶん違います
でそれをちょっと今日話してみたいです
でもう一つあのね賃貸する方一義というか批判っていうのはですね
ミラを生けるのは宴とって大拙だだからその時に過去の知識なんていうわけない
こういうふうにおっしゃる方は水ます
実際あの
そうですね社会が豊かな9件こくんととか
復興の時は駅舎大事だ自分たち団結しを損なうんですけども
社会を豊かになってくるとどの p でもですね
私の業者間区である中国であるとなんか最近学生の歴史に対する関心を据えてきた
また船集起業
でそういうことに対して私はどう言うかというとやっぱり
から違う
で
いい例がですねあのーでも東日本大震災して
福島原発事故を起こしたらも1000年間2000年1回地下起きないような大きな
津波が起きるということを無視してた所から来てもいい
専門書が付いてたんだけど多くの人はそれを無視した
ですから長期で受ける者だったら非常に身近なところで問題になることもよくある
そして針かこの地主義と結構でアジだということなんですよ
そして佐久間歯科医の福井さんのおっしゃったように
ネガティブなことばかりがある家の中にあるかとそうでもなくて
けっこうこれすごいなということもあるそれが
私は専門にしておりますので名自身の研究
でこれはですねあの名シーンの皆さんどういうことを思い浮かべられますよね
多分旺盛ブックなとか
改版治験行ったとかそれか文明開化を始めたとか
こういうところだと思うんです
ただ多分あなたかとあんま気が付いた愛情柔軟減収はい
メッセージますか
だいたい東端で
3万人ブラッ
様に言うとみんなからそんなにたのかこういうふうにおっしゃる可能性のフンは
熱心先行するフランス各メンバーですね
全体で200万くらいがなく
当時のフランスの人口は日本の年始の頃8%小さく
ですからこの当たる2桁のその犠牲者の数が違う
これは意味がある
どうしてちゃ迷信がそんなにいい選手を使うとそうなんだろうということを問題ない
で歌えは大変難しい
ですよね本当にだけどまぁ多分これは一つの解放だろうしている
考えるものがあります
これは明治の過程をですねあの図示したものです非常に簡略していますが
で
一番下からあのデーの名刺の出発雪考えて停留の外交でしてここから始まって上の方に
時間が動いて言ってサーブについては何かというと侍がいなくなっ
世界的見て鯖江たのは貴族の一種ですね
だ夫婦か侍と変わりなくなってしまう
これは大したものなんですそしてまあ家族とか後続とか
北1部まあ400円くらいだと思うんですその人たちを除いて後の日本人は全員が同じ
権利を持つようになりました
まあ近代史世界史資料裁断確認を一つ
しかしたらそこでも b 規制は少なかったが何度だろう
でこのつでですねあの
出発点は西洋の国々をやってどうもー
世界のほかのところ見てると日本も侵略されるかもしれない
こりゃ困ったらいうのを出発点だこれはずっと民主など一貫して心配されたことです
で
じゃあその時にですねにも守らなきゃって言った時にですね
最後に付いたところつまりダメ親サムランラクスことができたでしょ
サボその2本が折れたの頭じゃさむら歯科なっ
ですから出発点では絶対にそのさむらなくそーせい趣味をなくそうということはあり得
なかったん
そうするとこのボール向かって直進するという形で名刺を着ていない
むしろ
う変えろっ
でこのカエルポッターという場合にも意識的にあった場合と無意識にあった場合があり
ます
で
名神の後半はですね実はこれを意識的にあった場合
それは農政復興の直後からですねその薩摩長州黎弦うリーダーたちは次の課題は廃藩で
ある天皇もとにも日本国家を一つの口にしてしまう
江戸じゃあミター約210260くらいの国家連合した連邦国家であって一つの国家に
帰ってしまうと
だけどこれ口に出さないんですね実際にあの
軍事力も財力もですね駄目の本当に集結されている
なった時が
どうする間にプッシュは版
背反のちょ君ですねまあ名政府のリーダーの一人だったけど高いしてしていますが彼が
日記ですねここ3年半ぐらいでこれやってのけたんですけどここに至るは大変で苦労し
たと言っています
その頃したことの不ですねの一つが間オプション
はい版籍奉還として知られているんです
江戸時代の主完了します
デブ地雷ではですねそのとぐら将軍が話題が変わったときに誰よたちはみんな
当地許可を9か所ですね教科書もらったの一片返して新しい将軍からもらうことになっ
てました
ですからこの将軍いなくなって天皇がその新しい日本のシャア者になったんだから
まず天皇にその当地系箇所返そう
行ったらあまり抵抗がないわけです
で返したら先生を返してくれない
騙した犬種長瀬
あのまあその7たちはこちらの子で送らないんですね
元と同じ土地を治めるようになりましたがそれは面政府の官僚として納めるということ
になる
そしてはそのもう2年後にはその
そのための全体をなくしてしまう
でこういうふうに異種的に迂回作戦になった
これが明治の後半の出来事です
それに対してですねしかし幕末の枝十数年の清掃中ダメ
にタルトを着てるぞ
異種的に行ったんじゃないけれども知らず知らずのうち雲海のハマったんじゃないかと
いうことがあります
それはここに変えていますがその日本を守ろうってた時に最初にですねこれは大事だ
からこれを認めましょうと言われたのは講義公にすると
箱の外にいう人たちが日本の将来こうだった方がいいということを提案する
それまでは
西支店が意見を述べることを公の場で述べることは一切禁止されていましたバックの約
年ですが自分の担当以外のことを口はさんでいけない
それが安政5年に大きな製品が起きたときにその多分を解かれたんだ
そしてみんなが交渉亜洲敵の始めて10年経って旺盛行います
で大そく身体自体が実はこう行為をやろうというのをいう言葉が出てきた直後に生まれ
ていて順序とした講義の下げだったんですけど当確
あーだこーだ10年やっているうちに大政府のプチ
で王政復古行き着いた次は誰一の国が作ろう
こういうふうに
動いていたんです
ですからこれを全体としてみると大きなうカエルをとってこの頃運動だ
で直主は一切と可能ですね日本がをロッテと侍がなくなるんだけども
ウカールを取ったためにもう最初店素晴らしい結果が日本事前平等と古風なんです
というわけでまあこういうことを説明するとですね
ダークは二つでかなり興味持ってくれてです
いろんな社会がいろいろな問題を抱えていてその時にはもうお腹振らなきゃいけないと
いうふうに大きな問題を抱えて社会があります
何もしないわけしかしならその時に直進したらプラムを必ず
抵抗にゃああ
まあ大きな抵抗にあったことは犠牲者いっぱいでああ
だけどもそのとに迎えるを取れば抵抗が少ない人ひとつは大事なことだからみんな
いっしょきょうのしてみましょうというトナー完成ある
ということで免震の研究の中からは抜本的な社会改革というものを犠牲を少なくして
やる可能性が見えてくるんですね
それからもう一つ
これから未来の我々人類の社会はどうなるかということが問題でこれが今の我々に生き
方のその延長上にあるんだろうかと
手話なるんじゃないかと
歴史の中で詔勅人々当たり前だと思っていくコツがあってですがたとえ度ジャン人たち
は
鎖国がずっと続くと思っているそれで日本の部屋はもうな200年300年400円2
つだと思ってそう
実現車
で今の日本が都区部の前寝る優勝しているかとこのグラフですが
まあ細かい等を別にすればもう当確趨勢的にこのエネルギー消費量が上がっていって
ます
そして
声ネーションよ増えてのは色だけじゃないもっと急激に増えているのは世界最大の人口
大国である中国である
インドです
他の地域ももう経済成長を目指せ人間と一変欲望に目覚めたら本も取れません
ですから世界全体全将兵はもうますますを据えていくに決まっています
そうすると我は今使っている化石燃料請求とか試合方にも今使えるようになりました
けどそれはいくら増えたところで現場なんじゃないかと思われる
そうすると今の生活の延長上に見合う考える一つのシナリオ非常に強いしないですが
それ以外のシナリオもう考えていく必要が出てくると思う
その場合対応をしない考えするどれが当たるからで見ること分かりますいくつか考えて
いかなきゃいけない
その時に私は一つは定常社会を築く
成長ということがない社会をつくるということもあるだろうと思うんです
でこれについて日本手話ですね日の申しあげを提供していて江戸時代のようなそうです
はあの
江戸のまあ芝居小屋のあった街の
ですけれども
今はれはいっていうと全然ちっちゃー社会です
そこではですね人々はその社会が発展しないという全体ウッドできていました
研究によってゆっくりゆっくりと出会ったけど警察成長があったことは分かって社会
行動を少しは買いました
しかし人々は体感できないそうすると発展を前提しないでどうやって楽しくいけるかと
いうのが氏男子たちに一番重要な感想
でそれがよくわかるのはですね幕末にせよ人が日本にやって来て町こっちあるというの
はそれでいっぱい旅行教育です
その記述を見ているとですね日本じゃん非常に穏やかで物腰の柔らかい人たちで
非常にデーターし
これはですね貴族だったら世界中みんな同じ
高く日本は違うのは庶民までそう
微分の癒し今津人たちまで以上の穏やかでも腰があってえーっ
たぶんこれはそういう閉じられた世界でどのように短縮いけるかっていうことを考えた
ためそうなったんだろうともあるんですね
まあその具体的な工夫の例としては有名な茶の湯があります
江戸時代というのは議論厳しい36セルの社会ですよ壬生細かく分かれていて11その
下の人上にもうもの場合はその言葉遣いを気をつけなきゃいけないんだん行列が向こう
から空とホッパ逃げた方がいい風車逃げられなかったらその道端に土下座してそれも
通っていた非常に2力的なそういう3運勢ともがあります
しかしながらそういう社会のど真ん中にですね時とところを限って
その身分がない空間をつくっ
でお茶その入るとその時はそこに免れた人々はダメ男であると普通の侍であろうと場合
によっては承認であろうと義務も同じない
出ると思う
でその限られた空間の中で対等な黄砂を楽しい
それからもっとこれがあの後のように自分になったのはですね学校
えどちらの学校の主力はですねしじぷだったんですけど
成功がから金具んがそこにこう学んでる時だけは身分が消えてしまって年で6型て
しまって
そしてあの実力だが学問的地圖実力だけでは席上方を考えてすごいショットなります
そういうふうに閉じられた硬い社会であってもそこにゆとりを作る
1-1の月行きツヤできる空間を作るとそういう工夫がなされていたんです
ということでまぁ定住者買っていろんなタイプがあるかも知れ
でドジだしそのままだったら本当に私は嫌です嫌ですがそれでも
定常社会をがどういうものであるべきかというのを考えるときに江戸時代が参考になる
まあ sf をつくったりそういうアニメを作ってしたいろいろ面白いではこう笑いを
提供してくれと言うとこれは実際にあった話なんですよ
ということでまぁその歴史の中には日本様々の知的な
その蓄積があります
報告でそれを参照しながらその都度自分の都合に合ったものをを工夫していくっていう
ことが
歴史を3周することによって可能なんですね
これをですねあの有名なドイツの政治家がメスもあるん
こう言ってますね
愚者は経験に学び賢者は歴史ま
グシャッたのはラブ普通の文人で自分の経験で失敗する
そもそもこんなもんどちぱしたらどのきて次の時はうまくやると
その積み重ねています
シッパー経験の
反省た非常に重要なことです
しかしも飲む事と次第によって失敗したら溝と取り返しがつか長く人が対応してしまう
なったら
ですから自分の経験だけのたってたもう
もやておくれってこともあるそういうときには他人の経験を参照する必要がある
そのタイム経験性経験の集積こそが歴史に行わないんですね
ということでまぁビスグラフになって
武者は経験にまでペンじゃないちまだー
これは我々とってとても大事な事だろうと思うんです
ぜひ高校の時の悪夢をですねちょっと頭をすべきか決してでね
むしろその本屋に行って面白山門1点にとってですねアップルをもう一つ
片足てニっも2部は形から選んでください
きっと楽しいと思う
の前ん